I'm a doctor I'm a medical doctor not
only am i a medical doctor I went
through a pediatric internship and
residency I ran the pediatric emergency
room at Michael Reese
welcome to the Dean Sean idiot hole
subscribe if you haven't already this is
the continuation we are talking to dr.
Tony if you haven't seen part one go
ahead and check it out it will be in the
link below we're going to continue on
trying to get to the bottom of this
trying to see how we're going to follow
Jimmy Kimmel's advice shut the
conversation down or open it up based on
facts not fiction and follow the advice
of Robert DeNiro
remember there there is a link and
they're saying there isn't but there's
certain things there's a the obvious one
is thimerosal which is mercury-based
preservative but there are other things
there that I don't know I'm not a
scientist but I know because I've seen
so much reaction about justjust let's
find out the truth let's just find out
the truth they're both not experts in
this field that's why we're talking to
an expert in the area and that's what
intelligent people do they go to the
experts and if the truth is on your side
is going to set you free so enjoy the
rest of this week's show and then you
decide at the end this is the
back here with dr. Tony an expert in the
field has gone above and beyond what
your average doctor would know about
vaccines you could become an expert in
it you've uncovered a lot of things that
many people they just don't know they
don't learn in your conventional
schooling let's go to the next closet if
you don't vaccinate your kids it can
endanger their lives it can endanger
their lives so we would want the best
for our children so this doctors tell us
if we index if we don't vaccinate out so
we can endanger their lives what do you
say
if you vaccinate your child it can
endanger their lives too right so it's
which risk is riskier and you know there
are kids there people who are allergic
to penicillin and if you gave him
penicillin they would die right there
are so many kids who have died from
peanut allergy peanut oil was used as an
adjuvant in vaccines
people don't know that it was edge event
I think 69 there's so many parents
who've lost their kids from vaccination
where you know to think that the more
tip first of all the mortality rates
when we started vaccinating for all
these things that we vaccinate for are
no different than they are than they
were then so if you actually look at and
there's like a big graph and they do
little tricks so if they just show you
is like the few months before we
introduced the measles shot it looks
like it was low
it looks like the mortality rate was
high and then it dropped but the reality
is that if you look at from 1900 to
where we introduced the vaccines there
was a regression analysis that you can
do and the rate decline of of Mort all
cause mortality it was was declining on
its own so vaccines did not alter that
not one bit and in fact the rate most
deaths were from scurvy so vitamin C
deficiency we had high rates of scurvy
we didn't vaccinate that away we had
people dying from diarrheal illnesses we
didn't so your risk of death when you
got an infection was mostly from
diarrheal illness and from lack of
vitamin C right and once we introduced
IV therapies in the hospital right think
about it think about all the people who
come to the ER with dehydration if they
didn't get IV fluids and they were
vomiting and having diary
a sorry to be graphic but that's what
happens they would have died but just by
introducing IV fluid therapy in the ER
we don't die from having a virus and in
it you know that triggers diarrhea and
vomiting anymore right there's ways of
dealing with it so there were scurvy you
know vitamin C deficiency was huge
people lived in tenements they didn't
have sewage they didn't have you know
sewage treatment they didn't have
running water so when if you look at
actually when we introduced the measles
shot in the UK in Australia in Canada in
the US the death rate from measles was
what it is today right it's about one in
10,000 cases and it was before the
vaccine do we have less measles yes but
do we have other things from that
measles shot yes I believe we do you
know there's a lot of studies proving
Andy Wakefield's research was correct
that there's measles inclusion bodies in
the gut of kids with autism right and
it's the vaccine strains so there's now
a lot of neuro scientists I just saw an
article today looking at the gut brain
connection that you know autism and
antisocial behavior can be changed with
different probiotics so there is a lot
that we don't understand and I don't
think that peanut allergy and autism are
prices we should be paying for measles
we also have kids dying from the vaccine
by the way you know there's you know
several deaths a year from that shot
just to touch upon the dr. Wakefield if
someone says I mean because there's a
lot of controversy around him that did
he lose his license and some the
fraudulent paper what do you say if so
the paper was never proven to be
fraudulent he was never proven in a
court of law to do anything wrong in
fact so it was Andy Wakefield and his
whole research team I think there was
about 12 of them I'm not sure this is in
London and this is you know back in the
90s he was publishing papers early 2000s
and basically he published a paper based
on 12 cases where they examined the guts
of kids with autism and they all had
these changes in the gut that had
measles and the measles virus particles
in the gut and all he said was the
conclusion was that we need to look at
this further it was an implication that
there was a connection but he never said
stop vaccinating vaccines cause autism
he just said there
something here we need to look at he
wasn't even the first to say that by the
way and since then there's been dozens
if not maybe a hundred cases your papers
written about this when the team by the
time Andy moved to the States the court
case had come up for the rest of his
team and when I came to court it was
literally thrown out in the same day
there was zero evidence again against
them Brian deer had been hired he was a
journalist he had been hired presumably
by Rupert Murdoch and and Glaxo to smear
Andy Wakefield he claimed to have
patient charts
how did he get those patient charts how
would he have access to patients none of
those patients gave their charts over to
Brian deer all those patients actually a
hundred percent of those kids those
twelve families have stayed backing Andy
none of them said he violated them that
he committed fraud there's and there was
no court case to prove it so it has been
controversial in the sense that the
media doesn't want to publicize on the
fact that there was really no case
against him yes they took his license
away but this was the this is the ethics
board in the in in the in the UK and
they just recently took the license away
from a woman who who has very good
evidence showing that shaken baby
syndrome might not be shaken baby
syndrome so you know just for
disagreeing with mainstream thought that
might harm the pharmaceutical industry
you can get your license taken away
doesn't mean anything's been proven so
mainstream thought as the tobacco
industry that was a mainstream and what
wasn't that one time many doctors were
pushing more Similac and away from
breastfeeding oh absolutely well they're
doing that now you've got articles
saying delay breastfeeding because it
interferes with vaccination and one
thing for the powerful nutrients to get
him going we evolved over millennium
like that's not a perfect system I mean
that's a greater less mainstream back
then people doctors were pushing so I
mean well but I'll tell you one thing
about that so what the other side likes
to say isn't aluminum don't they finally
minim and formaldehyde in women's breast
milk yeah well guess what it's a
contaminant yeah cuz they've been
poisoned it's not normal oh it's in
there because
of course emanation yes of course
vaccines from drugs from you know
furniture I mean in the toxic inversion
of course it doesn't mean it's good and
I can tell you that aluminum Chris Exley
and his colleagues and cohorts around
the world and Chris Lexi's from Exeter
college he just published in nature a
paper on how toxic aluminum specifically
aluminum from a events are because the
other thing you'll hear from the other
side the industry side says you know we
eliminate can safely eat aluminum what's
injecting a little bit well guess what
from our mouth to our rectum we're an
open system so when you eat aluminum you
excrete it in your stool when you inject
aluminum it now has to go through the
blood and the serum into the kidneys and
it doesn't fit through those those we've
got a filtration system in it heavy
metals have a hard time going through
there and it can go right into the brain
so it's very different eating and
injecting you know ingesting and
injecting are not identical so it's this
is all industry speak that they like to
bring up as you know as to justify
poisoning us trying to get to the bottom
of this Robert DeNiro wants to get to
the bottom of this let's find out the
truth let's just find out the truth he's
had a child who's been affected Jimmy
Kimmel I don't know if he's had the same
but usually when traumatic instant
happens then it forces you to really
take a turn in light before that happens
let's get to the bottom of this so we
can make an informed decision we'll be
right back with more in today's show
don't go anywhere
to save one life is as if you've saved
all humanity show kindness to your
parents just as they cared for you when
you are young give in charity of the
good things you earn even a smile is a
charity explore the real values of Islam
find the missing piece at why Islam org
call us toll-free at 877 why Islam back
here on the D show dr. Tony someone
sends a community leader trying to get
their opinion and ask some questions
about vaccinating and the community
leader says I've looked into those and
others the vaccines but since me and my
wife and my kids all had vaccines no
problems as well as millions of others
in addition to the fact that for sure
many many people used to get measles
polio diphtheria etc and now nobody does
proves that it is what it is now it may
be that one in a million have an error
but after the measles outbreak recently
related to those not taking them safe to
say we should take them home here's a
fair would you there's so many problems
where do I start
so but since me my wife my kids all had
vaccines and no problems so other people
don't well that's like saying I don't
have I don't have allergies pollen and
hey you know pollen I'm not bothered by
pollen so therefore it doesn't bother
anyone else I can take penicillin so
people who claim to be allergic and
might die from penicillin should be
forced to take it too I mean it doesn't
prove nothing you know not all men are
bald but we know what's testosterones
related to fright I feed you know it's
so that means nothing
statement means nothing it clearly
doesn't understand science so there's no
there's no way that the outbreak by the
way was related to unvaccinated because
at least half of the people were known
to be vaccinated and could document it
and then you had another quarter who
said well I don't remember you think
that they were not vaccinated you know
they were like in their 20s and 30s or
40s they were probably vaccinated so
there was no proof that it was the
unvaccinated causing the outbreak and it
was what 600 in something cases for the
year that's nothing we had 40 cases in
New York City in 2014 that was connected
and identified and traced back to a
single 22 year old male who had just
been boosted with MMR and he spread it
to 40 people in New York City all who
had been vaccinated against measles so
and that was because they looked they
could type which measles strain it was
how do we know that people who are
recently vaccinate aren't spreading it
they're not allowed to see cancer
patients on cancer wards they're
spreading live viral mumps and measles
so you know it doesn't make any sense
and then the other thing is that it's a
risk and it's not one in a million and
it's not an error right we know that
it's not one in a million because we
have every single story when I testified
in Minnesota with the Somalian community
leader and the Somalian families we had
literally a stack of a few hundred
documents and every single one of them
was I was the same I went through them
and it was the day of getting the
measles shot that kid fever high-pitched
screaming seizure
the next day stop talking staring
couldn't connect I mean let's do the
next day
let it vary right away very easy to
convince a parent otherwise I mean it
really is it's kind of like I was hit by
a car my leg broke but I can't really
prove the car broke my leg I mean really
so you know we have a lot of problems
it's not one in a million and it's not
an error there are studies that happen
all over the third world that are
egregious in nature and Kashmir a few
years ago there were 27 deaths in one
area from an experimental news shot and
the local paper and the doctors the
hospital wrote that it was related to
the vaccine and when Gavi which is the
gates institute organization got in
there they rewrote a press release
he's saying all these kids died of
infection implying that the hospital you
know and the doctors are bad you know
and that all these kids had this you
know a an infection and died at the same
time so they're they're always washed
over but it's not an error and it's not
one in a million
think how many kids are now sick you
know all the autoimmune diseases that
we're seeing the exponential rate of
rise of Crohn's autism liver cancer
ulcerative colitis pots disease
postural orthostatic tachycardia Garlock
Odin didn't even exist before pots
disease was familial dysautonomia you
had to have two recessive genes to get
it and it was isolated to an Ashkenazi
Jewish population there were two centers
in the world that diagnosed it I worked
at one of them and now we have I see a
new Potts case every week they're not
Jewish they recently received a new set
of vaccines and it usually included that
Gardasil shot because the aluminum is so
guilty for causing dysautonomia I mean
so we've got a lot of problems and it's
not one in a million it's not from an
error it's just what is it's a side
effect for a lot of people based on
their genetics
so is it genetics at fault it's not
genetics at fault because if they
weren't exposed to these toxins they
wouldn't have these injuries but do
genetics play a part obviously do
epigenetics play a part I'm sure it does
you know I'm sure if you eat clink more
clean than somebody who's eating roundup
and pestis heavy resident have you
pesticide residue and high high sugar
diets they're going to respond poorly so
there's a lot of other things at play
but without given that trigger of the
vaccine that person would have been fine
let's go to the next clip get your
feedback on that potential downsides of
vaccinations are almost non-existent the
cumulative scientific and medical
communities are in absolute full
agreement that there is basically no
reason not to vaccinate your kids okay
well this is a PSA and you know I first
of all the laughter on his show for the
for this segment was canned I mean don't
you agree that's canned laughter that
you're hearing you and I don't think the
audience would be laughing nobody's
laughing at vaccine injured kids right
and I can't go anywhere I can't fly
anywhere in this world without sitting
next to somebody in a plane who's got a
vaccine injury story so it's not one in
a million
it's a lot of people when I made my
documentary you know but when I worked
on bought wherever we went there were
people who would ask us Oh what
documentary are you making and like
whether it was our server or the host at
the hotel
you know everybody would be like oh yeah
I totally get it I know somebody
everybody knows somebody so when they
say the potentials side effects are
moans almost not okay really to say okay
I can bet you that none of these doctors
know what the vaccine court is if you
ask any of these doctors what's the
national vaccine compensation program
what year was it senators people what's
the table of injuries so far 3.5 billion
you know which is a fraction by the way
of what should have been paid out and
it's only those people that haven't
reported well well most cases don't get
reported why I didn't know viras existed
I didn't even know Vera's the vaccine an
adverse event risk reporting system
existed until a few years ago I ran a
pedes er I didn't report any of those
cases that came in with SIDS
or they came in with apnea or that came
in with seizures no one else in my ear
did I didn't know I was supposed to I
didn't know there was a system to report
it so if I didn't know I doubt most
other doctors knew because if they did I
would have been told by my senior
doctors so they don't know because I can
tell you that every time I'm in court on
vaccine custody issue in state court and
I'm up against one of these doctors who
say this they don't know the facts they
don't know what they don't know what the
table of injuries is they don't know any
of this stuff this is just propaganda
what about when when they say it's a
consensus is it because it is a
consensus so what science isn't settled
by consensus you know it isn't science
facts don't exist because of consensus
right the consensus was the world was
flat does that mean that it was true
because that was the consensus you know
our theories are you know theories
physics theories change all the time you
know we find that we're wrong about
things all the time tobacco the
consensus was that tobacco was not only
safe but that cigarettes were good for
you the consensus was that cocaine
coca-cola had cocaine in it that was
great it was great for you I mean these
things change all the time it has to do
with the money and the influence and
what's being politicized and what's not
and you know okay some people say is
profit over people
it's profit over people you
got it let's take a let's go to one more
before we go to break okay which is why
I cannot believe we have to make this
PSA I had to go to school for eight
years
I'm pretty sure I know what I'm talking
about now I have to use my only day off
to talk to you idiots about vaccines I'm
watching Breaking Bad I'm only halfway
through the second season I went to
school I pretty I'm pretty sure I know
what I'm talking about
they're pretty sure not certain though
and then and then why you know a lot of
times you you're here this dirt is the
rogatory language you know oh yeah shut
the gas station down yeah this is
something that Robert De Niro if you're
scientists let's see let's hear
everybody doesn't seem to want to hear
much about it it shut down well he talks
about why shut the conversation let's
have your scientist you're done let's
talk about well I challenge a lot of
people to debates and on Twitter on
Facebook but mostly on Twitter these
days I was supposed to debate with with
Paul Offit on Fox radio and the day
before he bowed out he must have vetted
me and realized and they said you don't
debate video you'd open debate gravity
so I actually tweeted to him and found a
group of physicists who actually debate
gravity it was like lookee here Paul
even physicists debate gravity you know
like we don't know everything about
everything Paul knows the truth I mean
he clearly knows what's going on he's in
it for the money and he's an evil person
he's not acted with the farm oh yeah
he's got a raise out of vaccine the
motive virus vaccine which has caused
over 400 deaths that I know on she makes
money on which he makes money off of
well he says he sold it but he made you
know at least and I mean big estimates
are about 26 million but he so he sits
on a chair that gets him 1.5 million
it's a Merck chair but there's at least
400 infants who died from taking that
vaccine we don't need a rotavirus
vaccine in our country we don't need it
in the Western world it's a non-issue
it's a live virus that gets taken orally
or intranasally and it's live so that's
shed and it's caused diarrhea but people
don't know that these doctors don't
bother looking at that they've probably
net have read of Vera's report in their
life so yes I went to four years of
undergraduate and four years of med
school and I did four and a half years
of residency because also trained in
rehab and I ran a pedes ER and I also
have a mass
and medical science and I also have an
environmental degree but or
accreditation but you know we didn't
study vaccines in any of that stuff
I studied vaccines and my master's
because I was told to stay on that task
when I uncovered the truth about that
flu shot III also I was astonished to
find out that doctors really don't even
study nutrition in medicals oh you have
a week of biochemistry and it's called
nutrition I mean most doctors will still
tell you you know oh you shouldn't eat
high fat and you should have eight
servings of grains a day and my time the
key to good health is it of course it is
yeah let's take a break and we'll be
right back to wrap this up here on the
Dean show don't go anywhere
when I embrace the slam from that day on
I knew I never wanted to drink another
drink in my life I never wanted a smoke
I never wanted to earn my body because I
realized that it was a blessing you know
to be able to see life from the
perspective of Islam because it's like a
lens that clarifies life for you and so
I started seeing the clarity of life and
I said this is what I've been looking
for all my life now all I have to do is
live up to it before I get to talking
about all the wonderful topics we'll be
talking about on the show subscribe
right now are you sick of feeling empty
inside there's a void in your heart and
you tried everything to fill it with but
you haven't figured out the purpose of
life that's one of the major things we
talk about here in the D show and most
definitely we're gonna be talking about
Islam
why not it's one of the hottest topics
that's in the world today and we're
going to be covering every misconception
that revolves around
Islam Islam stance on women terrorism
jihad you name it we're going to be
striving our best to talk about it here
in the D show subscribed right now
and also a wide array of many
contemporary topics party music and play
how does that fit into this way of life
did you know that Muslims love Jesus
we'll be talking about him too we'll be
talking about atheism and why stop there
we cover topics that have to do with
family sports nutrition a wide spectrum
of different topics that we cover here
in the Dean show subscribe right now
got hummed it a lot we've been doing
this over 10 years 500 plus episodes and
we bring on some of the most amazing
guests so we're going to have a lot of
fun cover a lot of ground a lot of
exciting topics you don't want to miss
out you want to be here every Friday and
then we'll try to give you some short
reminders in between but you can't get
that if you're not coming back to the
show every week
Friday's will be releasing it God
willing inshallah subscribe right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like and
don't forget as I asked you to do
already if you have it subscribed right
now back here on the Dean show where dr.
Tony and expert in this area we are
sincerely trying to get to the bottom of
this make an informed decision let's go
to one more clip final one now I have to
use my only day off to talk to you you
needs about vaccines what if I'm
watching Breaking Bad do something we've
been doing for a century some more on
it's your kids vaccinated get your kids
vaccinated or lose my number
okay the point I want the points I wanna
I want to talk about besides calling
each other morons and stuff that's not
going to help you know get to the bottom
of this is the people who might you're
obviously not someone who just read an
email and ya know and most people aren't
by the way what but when see when people
who work for the Centers of Disease
Control they come out like you had when
was that recently and they're telling us
there's something's going on when we
have people who work for the big
pharmaceutical companies they are
telling us
yeah we've whistleblowers everywhere so
we have a CDC whistleblower we have a
dutiful company with exact thousands of
doctors neurologist from Merck who are
with blowing the whistle exactly I mean
these people don't know anything about
the CDC whistleblower they don't know
anything about the pharmaceutical
whistleblowers they don't know that
Merck is under investigation and has a
federal case against two cases against
them for falsifying the mumps part of
the vaccine I mean there's you know one
thing after another and to shut down the
the conversation because you'd rather
watch Breaking Bad instead of learning
for yourself first of all most of these
parents know way more than those doctors
they they don't it's not an email that
they're basing their their whole
judgment on they are
the data I mean I know parents who know
more about the innate immune system and
the vaccine cord and the ingredients and
research on aluminum adjuvant then then
probably 99% of the doctors I know so I
mean that and that's a sad statement so
because these guys are going off belief
they they've probably never looked at
the real issue in the data and also the
side effects is it really worth it to
live with Crohn's and also colitis or MS
or ALS at 18 instead of having mumps and
measles and time is it really worth it
to have that I don't think so
is it true that we spend the most on
health care by the sickest we're 47th or
47th in health in health outcomes
so there's 40s there's 46 countries who
have better health outcomes than we do
and we spend by far by a net by an
exponential degree more in health care
per person per capita than any other
country is it can you say I mean I've
heard this thrown around it's it's a
business being sick it is a business you
think I asked because I'm trying to
envision if some of these you know
corporate giants from the big pharma
they come around and are like you know
what we're going to cure this disease
this disease today we're let's rid the
world of you know and save the world
from all of these chronic diseases or I
think like or do they sit around
thinking like how can we make more
Benjamins that makes more sense yeah
right because then they'd be out of
business well it's you know it's there's
a lot of money keeping people crippled
so if you can induce autoimmune disease
and just about everybody
they'll there and then convince them
that they need to stay on your biologics
which are about $15,000 a an infusion
every month think about all the money
you're making I mean it's huge how many
people had I heard somewhere around over
60% of Americans are on prescription
drugs yeah and even over 50% of kids are
on prescriptions or food chronically for
some chronic problem yep
whether it's attention deficit or asthma
or you know yep
are we the leading killer of children we
are we there's about I think we're
number 37 in infant mortality so that
means 36 countries ahead of us that have
better infant mortality rates and even
if you adjust for preemies because what
you'll hear other
say well that's because we say more
preemies no it's even adjusted and even
up to age six we still have a high
pediatric mortality rate we have very
high pediatric infectious-disease rate
deaths death rate right so I thought
we're giving all these vaccines to
prevent these infectious diseases but
guess what you just shift one virus for
another so hip vaccine got rid of the B
hip him off listen blends up B but guess
what now we have as high or higher a
rate of infectious and invasive disease
with non B Hamas influenza yeah you have
like I believe it's France where they
only do three vaccines is it four well
for the most part they and they're not
mandated for school they're not mandated
for school even I think here it's 35
before school is there is there anything
seeing what's there
where are they as far as Health much
healthier much health much health but I
told you something right there in other
countries that vaccinate less are we are
we dictation so look at Gary Goldman and
Neil Miller's research on on mortality
rates actually laid on over the rates of
vaccination and it's very clear that the
countries that vaccinate the most in the
earliest have higher mortality rates are
there any sign if someone says look
science has closed the door on this well
science is never settled okay so no
scientist says science is settled
because that's not real science is it no
so what's your advice you're you're
you're an expert in this area
everybody has to speak out stop saying
autism stop saying and say vaccine
injury because that's what it is you
have to pressure your politicians at the
local level we need to get away we need
to do away with super PACs and citizens
united and you need to pressure your
local politicians to not vote for Pharma
to not be in Pharma's hands and tell
them that you will not get them back
into power you will not vote for them
back into their position
the net good next go around everyone
needs to speak out and be not hide you
know people need to come out of the
woodwork because there's a lot of people
who know this there's a fair amount of
doctors who know this but they're afraid
to speak out I get emails and letters
all the time thanking me and I'm like
you know what we need you to speak out
to it can't just be a few thousand
doctors around the globe or you
tens a few tens of thousands of doctors
around the globe it's got to be a lot of
them so there's a lot of closet docks
yes they're ready to come out they're
just nurses absolutely absolutely
where can people get more information
you have a blog well I'm I can be found
at disease - reversal calm and that's my
website I don't necessary but if people
follow me on twitter at dr. sensation or
my facebook page Center for disease
prevention reversal or Toni bark MD or
Toni bark
you know I post a lot of stuff there is
safe minds there are sane VAX there's
the NVIC org there's a bunch of websites
we can get really good solid information
are you willing to come back if we have
somebody on the medical industry and
they are like you know what we wanted I
want to I want to dialogue with fur -
great for you to come back on you got it
you got it cat it dr. Toni god bless you
thank you so much for being with us
thank you thank you thank you guys for
tuning in such a hot topic so important
and many of us we don't and we don't
focus on these important issues look you
can be involved in so many noble causes
great causes but if this blessing of
health gets affected not only can it
slow you down tremendously where you're
not at your optimal performance level
but it totally all the good work gets
shut down and now you join the over 60%
of Americans or others want some
prescription drugs that don't take care
of the problem the root problem but mass
it's like putting a band-aid over to
check engine light or taking the fuse
out when you see the check engine light
on 50% of people living today will have
cancer one in three men will die from it
it's a serious issue and we need to take
the matter of food seriously what kind
of foods we're putting into our body and
not just being program thinking there's
a pill for every ill the reality that
there's a big business and people being
sick and there are term a tremendous
amount of good health practitioners
doctors out there who not only care
have the right information who have gone
above and beyond what they've learned in
medical school because nutrition is the
key one of the keys formulas to good
health but it's not taught in medical
school I didn't know it
doctors experts are telling me and
there's a lot of other things that
weren't taught and many have been taught
how to prescribe drugs I don't want to
be on no drugs as a last resort maybe
but I want to try everything possible to
put everything good in my body and I'm
sure you do also things that real food
energy living components that help to
heal not to destroy the gift of health
that the Creator has given us so much
more to talk about this God willing I'll
be down the line going over bringing out
more experts to cover health to cover
nutrition because this is a key to us
living a vibrant good life health gets
affected all the work is shut down
health is strong families strong mind is
clear you can continue to continue your
wonderful work with more energy more
vibrancy you're able to accomplish much
more I hope that at the end of this we
can get stimulated to look into the
matter more to get informed educated
look at both sides look at the evidences
the the proves this is what our Creator
tells us to do and I hope that you enjoy
continue to tune in to the D so every
week a new exciting show inshallah God
willing subscribe if you haven't already
until next time peace be with you